куди б напишу у мадриді луїс перес
скривила переслідуючи трагічно минуло
у години військової диктатури франсіско
франко людина за знавши коту ваня і цим
уроки віце div ув'язніть 80 і річкові луїс
перес доки давид то медальний за крему
на дні treasury що видон та льотчик був у
публічний ком франко то razon знаємо
боровся просто демократів та мадрид мою
matter переслідував це та очевидно
куліть режиму франку менеза проторив
душі знаєте скільки я боровся за свободу
і демократію та за наймом комун шосе на
збувалося знову року жертв франкізм
більше мешканці вулиці команди rosary ти їм
свої думки
ново назвав це означало б зміну адреси
бюрократичну texan ii ну особливо його
протестує владно до різьблених захоплень а
джеєм здогадається за мавля ти на вигляд
проспект це візи дівки називають нас
кондитерську на вулиці суре ти
5 і звані видами ось чому нам ціна
skoda нас можна його перестануть доходи ти
кретова переманювання нічого не дасть
генерал millan гострий би довідатися а там
фашистам та за основу на кому іноземного
легіони іспанії міністр пропаганди яки
брутально розправлявся за ніг одуматися
me all in і всі поважають та піднесений сам
адвокат гільєрмо рука ford в
організовуючи спрут перейменований не
звільніть гостра
хочемо надягаючи браслет і на замовлення
генерала
1 кого генерала шлях 6 правих колах у
вежі та даси
у фашистських ідей і нині і слідом
онуки теж проти не історії на бува
особливого значення але корінних про що і
навіщо від давньої рани али наша влада не
рано стіни загорівся тому ми боремося за
то щоб трималося творила комісію
спосіб уест ручної правди залишилося
серпні я краю треба було романська вина
у крем kobo читай спаміш cambodia
іспанія lfc на народжує на ставок ідей
управляти чуя народну партії та ціни
давно а джині і заснув of кілочки
міністр франко франки вам на всякому
нерівність боїться ринку і див дасин і за
су джин та в іспанії до сиз но я фонд
імені франсіско франко кают раму та тремтіння
у не дотації там вчили її правління
партії повстане з вважали цінував прочитав
в цій історії манас монтери луїс pro100
Еньші жертви з подіваються ще рано
джей-пі знову йти мадрида пофарбувати
ними нас правді
вигідних людей